[Applause]
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
[Applause]
[Music]
We take it
far. We go all the
way. Everywhere you
are and everywhere you
go, you're hero of who we are. We take
it
far. We go all the way.
[Applause]
[Music]
Stone
face was just a snotty nose kid with a
cloudy head. They say our rules was paid
for it, but I didn't figure out a jumpy
little never threat. I realized it
didn't matter. I was destined to melt to
death. You live your life scared, you
going to die there. You live your life
where you going to die rare. The mind is
a safe place, but when the skyscrapers
crash to the ground, you can't hide
there. This life is cooler than you
think it is. Yeah. These illusions
trying to save the scene. Anytime the
big picture is neglected, we're on the
verge of making a decision, it is
restless. Now my mind's on autopilot,
making decisions in the now.
that my heart will guide it. Instead,
he's scraping off the dark side. Now,
when I'm looking for that mental safe
place, it's hard to find it.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
[Applause]